Dr David Cook was the mental training
coach for the NBA champion San Antonio
Spurs he coached Legends like David
Robinson and Tim Duncan as well as
hundreds of PGA NFL and major league
baseball players in this exclusive
interview with Chris Weidner you'll hear
David's best advice on the psychology of
winning how to optimize your mental game
for Peak Performance and how to overcome
your fear of failure and we got Chris's
permission to put it up on our YouTube
channel enjoy our guest today is David
cook David is president of his San
antonio-based Peak Performance firm that
Bridges the gap between the sports and
business Arenas as well as speaking and
coaching he directs creative leadership
Retreats that incorporate golf and or
Wilderness adventures in the Texas Hill
Country David has been named one of the
top 10 sports psychologists in the world
is known as a leading Authority in the
science of Peak Performance and
represented the United States at the
international Olympic Academy in Olympia
Greece he is a frequent speaker for the
prestigious Zig Ziggler Corporation has
served as mental training coach for the
world champion San Antonio Spurs and
counseled hundreds of top athletes in
businesses such as Exxon and American
Express good to have you here David what
a great time to be here yeah it's going
to be fun um okay so here's my question
yes let's Dive Right into this sports
psychologist what's the difference
between standing over a 4ot putt wherein
if you miss it you have to buy beer for
your bud in the 19th hole and standing
over a 4ot putt for
$400,000 I tell you for a lot of guys
there's not that much difference you
know a lot of people that play this game
they uh they put too much of their s
into it and so that putt missing that
putt has a whole lot to do with their
ego and who they are and their whole
self-identity sometimes golf means too
much and that's what CS what we call The
Yips right it causes people to have all
that stress and anxiety so in a way I
mean obviously it's different but in a
way when these guys are playing with
their buddies that they live with that
are going to harass them or celebrate
with them or needle them or whatever
that 4 foot putt means a lot and often
times causes great stress and gra great
anxiety what do people think about
though some some people you know they're
just playing a backyard game or whatever
uh but then they get to this and now it
means something how does that part about
meaning create the inability to make a
putt that they could make all day long I
tell you and here let me give you an
example of something that you can try to
see about that meaning take a putt take
a ball and put it 6 in from the hole and
see what you're thinking as you take the
putter back and hit it nothing take it
back a foot nothing take it back two
feet nothing somewhere between 2 feet
and four feet you take it back and
people all of a sudden they start start
thinking I could miss this or this is a
real putt or this is not a gimme and and
so there's a point at which we move away
from that goal there's a point at which
that goal gets far enough away from us
that all of a sudden different voices
begin to speak to us it's the same in
life it's the same in in in and in
anything once we start adding meaning
it's meaningless at 6 Ines it's
meaningless at a foot it's meaningless
at 2 feet but at 3 feet there's a threat
and the threat happens around 3 feet
because it's short enough you should
make it and so if you miss it it really
must mean you're not very good um or you
can't get it back it's you know it's
it's Gone Forever um but meaning
comes uh as we in sport in life as we
Define the you know what it what it
means to our ego to our self-confidence
to our
self-concept and what I try to teach
people is you know it means too much
let's really look at the truth instead
of the LIE the LIE is always that a putt
going in the hole or a basket going in
the basket or a field go going through
the uprights says something about me
that's true to the world and our culture
puts it right out there in front of
everybody and either you're a failure
you're a loser you're the goat and
that's your label yeah because that's
what television entertainment that's
what the fans say without understanding
that that has nothing to do with the
worth of a man and but that's sort of
what we built in this culture my job
does it go both directions do we say if
I make this I'm great if I miss it I'm
bad and the fact is is that neither are
true absolutely so so it's about it's
about knowing who you are aside from
your performance absolutely there's a
head and a heart part of what I do the
head part teaches people how to deal
with the interference in the context of
the uh performance setting that they're
in the heart is about the perspective
that they take into that contest and U I
think in in my field probably in in the
performance Psych ology feel overall the
number one issue is the fear of failure
and the fear of failure causes people to
walk into a contest with baggage on
their shoulder before the game ever
begins in other words they've taken
their potential and they've lessened it
before they ever get to the field
because they've taken something into the
field with them that is not necessary to
be there and it keeps them from being
free to perform and to do the best they
can you don't get to be in the NFL
unless you win a lot unless you're very
good athlete you don't get to the PGA
Tour unless you can deliver you don't
get to that level why then even at that
level after having proven for 15 or 20
years that you are the top one of the
top 100 players in the world do you
still have a fear of failure well
several things number one it's a
movement in a level uh the the people
that win the the major Awards in the
different sports this year in college
are moving to a pro level next year yeah
it is really no different than the kid
that played junior high ball moving to
high school and the high school player
moving to college the college moving to
to professional every time you move a
level most people that are just normal
people there's a question in their mind
can I make that jump am I good enough
and usually what happens is that we've
idolized some of those people that are
just in that level above us and all of a
sudden we're surrounded by them I can
remember one of my uh PGA Tour clients
one day calling me up and saying I'm
paired with him I said you're paired
with who I'm paired with Jack and this
was back in the 80s and they were both
in contention actually for this golf
tournament Jack Nicholas and the
gentleman I was working with he said
it's the first time he said I'm paired
with my idol this is the guy I grew up
thinking about my entire life I mean
since a kid was six years old so Jack
was at the you know the the end of his
career and this kid was at the beginning
of his career they're both in contention
their 10 underpar going into the last
day and they're paired together he says
what am I supposed to think about it was
a great question this kid was good he
had made it to the professional levels
he was on tour he had won a golf
tournament but the issue now was he's
stepping it up a level he's now paired
with the greatest of all time and he
wanted to know what am I supposed to
think because my mind is is all over the
place and we understand my background in
sports
psychology really sports psychology is
the study of the Mind in performance
it's sport you know we can set that
aside it happens to be how
in the sport but in fact it's really the
study of the mind and performance and
doesn't matter if it's business if it's
drama if it's music if it's uh Sport and
so the issue we understand is that game
day is different than any other day in
life and my profession what I spend my
life my passion is teaching people how
to perform their best when it means the
most for this particular gentleman it
was I'm playing with my idol there's a
big piece of interference out there and
I want to do my best in front of him um
interesting what' you tell him you know
what I told him and I think it's true
for all of us number one count it a
blessing that you get to you get to
perform next to your Idol number two
understand that the 30,000 people that
came to watch Nicholas today are going
to be introduced to the next Champion
your job today is to stay into your game
play your own game don't apologize for
getting in his way or out of his way you
play your game he is no different than
anybody else a competitor on game day
and you can't allow him to take you out
of his game respect him honor him all
that stuff but you play your game and at
the end of the day know that if you play
your game you play stay in the process
that I that I teach um that you'll have
30,000 fans that you didn't have count
it a blessing look forward that's an
interesting Theory I want to ask you
about that that count it a blessing he
shows up and and I suppose anybody could
apply this anywhere he shows up and he's
playing with Jack Nicholas and and he's
thinking
oh no you know and and he puts this
meaning attaches this meaning to it
instead of going how great is this right
I've looked at this I've wanted to meet
this guy for ages and now I get to play
around with him and it's just that it's
a just a mental shift right right it the
truth you asked me the question why
would they fear failure on that day yeah
is he's got 30,000 people usually
there's 10 or 15 people watching him so
yeah if he makes a mistake it's
exaggerated you know to 30,000 eyes it's
it's like speaking to an audience so 10
people vers speaking to a 50,000 people
yeah you know if you make a blunder with
10 people it's okay 50,000 you're scared
to death that they're going to remember
that forever and so as you move up in
the sport World As you move up as a
leader in your organization or position
as you move up in an organization and
business the pressure mounts because
there's more people and more eyes upon
you there's more
responsibility and and and so we see
that the mistakes really uh cause more
people to have opinions about us if we
live by what I call the Great American
trap the Great American trap
states that um a person's Identity or
worth is equal to their
Performance Plus the opinions of others
so many people that are watching this
program right now understand that it
clicks in their heart and they don't
like it yeah because it is absolutely
the formula for the fear of failure and
the issue in life for us to understand
that's why I talk about the heart and
the head is you got to take the right
perspective into the performance setting
meaning you understand where the worth
of a man or woman comes from it comes
from character it comes from faith comes
from relationships it comes from
Integrity you know it comes from value
it comes from um uh the way you go about
what you do uh being honest and truthful
all those character traits yet the
culture really looks at one thing I mean
if we can sort of look at the American
culture is that we have a scoreboard
every day and at the end of the day
there's a
score and there's not a first place
second place third place fourth place
the scoreboard at the end of the day you
won or you lost for so many people and
at the end of the day we see that we
failed and so the people that live to
that
formula their self-worth their identity
is really beaten up they
feel they just feel awful at the end of
the day like a loser because they base
their identity on the
Performance Plus what they think other
people are going to think about them
because of that performance that's a
that's a sad thing in our culture sure
you know I love the free enterprise
system and I love competition that's why
I'm in yeah what I'm in and and there's
a certain way to think in the
competitive environment to be the best
you can be but you've got to understand
you must start with the right
perspective and have a foundation there
so that you don't haul in this fear of
failure baggage that that attacks people
when the performance and opinions of
others is what makes them who they are
um once I've got their heart right then
I can really begin to help them
understand the process of thinking so
that they have a chance for their
potential to rise so is that the process
that you start when you're working with
an executive or you're working with an
athlete do you start by by addressing
the hard issues do you say hey we're
going to get to the in a minute but
first we got to find out what all these
things are that you place is that the
process you know I've done this for 20
years now and the in The Last 5 Years
absolutely I cannot start with a head
only huh I had a player on the PGA tour
a few years ago in a particular
tournament that I was in and and he
asked to come in he was he was he was
about to lose his card it was near the
end of the year the first time in seven
years the guy really lost his playing
privileges and he was afraid and cuz he
wasn't high enough in the money wasn't
high enough in the money at a few
tournaments too the the odds of him
winning those tournaments in his mind
were were Neil but he one last ditch
effort he wanted to really work to see
if there's a if anything in his mind
would help him to perform to a higher
level the kid was so
skillful when I speak with a group of
people when I'm working with individuals
at that level I always began like
yesterday I was in Houston with a great
Corporation the room was full of 75
Executives of one of the best companies
in America and it was easy to look out
and say the issue in this room has
nothing to do with
potential I've talked with your leaders
I understand who it is that's in this
room the Gathering of the resources that
make up who you are the potential that's
right here in this room is not at issue
what's at issue is how do we allow that
potential to come out on game day my job
as a as a performance coach as a Peak
Performance coach mental trainer in
sport in business is to help people
understand that having potential is not
enough that you've got to you've got to
be able to manifest that potential on
game day it's got to come out when it
means the most and so we need to
understand what that environment's like
and we'll get to that in a few minutes
this particular player had great skill
he he was one of 154 golfers in this
particular tournament they could have
won the golf tournament we went through
the process the mental process of
understanding that in the context of a
competitive environment you have one
thing that you have absolute control
over and that's what you think and
that's the one thing that people give
up they they allow the external factors
to come in and dictate their thinking
and to create barriers and obstacles and
adversity within their mind which keeps
them from being able to filter down to
the one thing they have control over and
that's a thought process so the one
thing you have control over is what you
think then people when they understand
that their next question is so what am I
supposed to think and that's what I
teach people I go through a process and
it you know it' be particular to
whatever environment they might be in so
you know there's no one Pat answer that
covers everything but we do know let's
talk about your setting let's talk about
the environment let's talk about the
skills needed and let's create a process
oriented thought structure that what we
call mental Journey that you go through
before you pull the club back shoot a
free throw walk into an interview let's
let's take two of those I want to give
you two two the let me finish the
storyy I don't want them to hang hang on
the story so yeah I taught him the
process and and he knew the process but
it was good for him to to hear it we
went out and hit balls and practice and
I walked around with him and then the
tournament began and he hit a
magnificent drive off the first hole I
mean way down the Fairway and then he
walked with a
look of a
defeated human being down to his ball
his shoulders were slouched his head was
down he was slower than the other guys
walking and you could look at him and
think where is this man what's going on
in his life between the first and he
pared the first hole but between the
first hole and the second T box you
can't coach out there the caddy and you
are the only ones that can speak but I
stood right between there and I looked
at him and I just said I got a question
for you
I want you to think about something it
wasn't coaching I was just asking a
question like a spectator might ask a
player do you remember the first shot
that you hit as a PGA Tour player seven
years ago where was it what was it
like he raised up he
looked he thought about it he said it
was
unbelievable and I said where is that
man what's the difference between then
and now and what happened is he lost his
love for the game he had lost his
passion and desire for winning golf
tournaments and he was playing that day
going through the motions even the
mental motions without a heart and if
you don't play with a heart you're not
going to win a golf tournament you might
hit some good shots but you got to carry
yourself Like A Champion you got to
Think Like A Champion you got to have
your mind clear and you got to be
competing for the top prize and not
taking up space and for him
it was a matter of the heart he's on his
way back now he missed a tour and had
some family issues and all kinds of
things he's on his way back now but it
was really for him a regathering of
himself and creating the passion for
what he was out there for for him was
about the heart I do not you ask the
question I will not start with anybody
without understanding first of all tell
me about your heart tell me about your
perspective tell me about how you feel
about this
formula selfworth equals Performance
Plus the opinion opinions of others and
if
they
hesitate and think deeply about that you
know they're carrying the fear of
failure and so we talk through that we
got to we got to remove that we got to
get out there and play for it a little
white ball going in a hole yeah sure has
a not a whole lot to do with life a you
a free throw going into a hoop doesn't
have much to do with life now for all
you coaches and all you Executives and
CEOs and presidents before you write me
off you got to understand I've been
doing this for 20 years I've seen people
succeed at the highest level I've been
with the Spurs through two World
Championships I was with the Wizards
last year when they got in the second
playoff for the first time in 25 years
I've been with players Five Guys on the
PGA tour that won for the first time
I've been to the Olympics in Atlanta
I've been to the British Open the US
Open I've been to all these places and
seen Champions and I've just got to say
that success at the highest level with
the greatest performers in the world has
never fulfilled one person that I've
ever worked with or seen win a trophy
and so until we get the heart right that
success is going to be meaningless when
you get there so let's work on both
things let's work on the heart have the
right perspective so that the journey is
really worth it and when you get to the
end it's just a destination it's not the
end and let's see that it opens up a
whole new door for another opportunity
and let's live with a life of purpose
and let's think right so that you can
get there those are the two big deals
that I work with I think it was Vince
Lombardi who talked about the the the
Roar of the crowd and the noise and the
arena and then but ultimately you leave
that you leave the championship field
and you're back in your room by yourself
and I don't remember the exactness of it
but he made he was making that point of
you know that's a moment yeah and that's
great and it's fun and it's it's worthy
of pursuing But ultimately your moments
outside of that are so much more and so
much more important they are yeah when
you you know people come to the end of
their life it's always about
relationships it's always about
um uh did their life stand for something
did they leave something behind did they
have a
legacy um I really believe in legacies I
think people ot to live for legacies
that they they should they should wake
up every morning and know what it is
that they're living for and then make
sure what they do during the day meets
meets that end goal I really am a big
big deal in Legacy we don't have much
time here let's make sure it lasts and
let's don't let's don't have a legacy
that I held a trophy one day let's have
a legacy that that
trophy that that trophy went Way Beyond
a piece of metal yeah that it opened the
door to things and people's hearts and
and that's really what it is it's it's a
door opener if all you can say at the
end of your life was I won 14
tournaments or I was the heavyweight
champion of the world for a year and a
half you know but if those things then
allow you to open up other doors that
create your life right that can then be
summed up in in your in your uh eulogy
then that's really what you're saying
life is all about and and it it's sort
of counterintuitive really the way you
work this is important winning a winning
a championship is important but this is
so much more important and in order to
make this happen you've got to deal with
the much more important thing first the
question is this why is winning a
championship important not that winning
a championship is important why is
winning a championship important why is
getting this position important why is
selling uh this much and reaching this
bar
important because and you've got to
answer the question and if that answer
falls into the category of my purpose in
life you go to work with passion every
day do you ever find people that just
you work with an athlete very skilled
and you ask them that question and they
just
go absolutely I I don't know why because
it's what I've always you know they
that's interesting fascinating and it
has to do with leadership that there's
either parents or leaders around them
never really helped them see beyond the
success that they might have um I've
worked with so many absolutely
incredible
performers that were lost deeply lost in
life and and their social abilities and
their physical abilities were miles
apart and their social and mental
abilities kept them from allowing this
incredible potential to rise and that's
the debate today about letting young
kids become professionals at an early
age and things like that I mean going
from college to the pros in the NBA yeah
versus spending four years with a guy
like Roy Williams or Mike shashy or
someone like that can you imagine the
difference that that person when they go
straight to the pros they don't have
that mentoring process I mean they're
thrown into the lines immediately you're
supposed to pick up this deal and get
after it it's a business you can be
there today and gone tomorrow and
College there's a family around you
there's an atmosphere there's discipline
there's there's all those things I
really am an advocate for um allowing
kids to mature at a proper level now you
know what there's some there's some
young people that are mature in certain
sports that that you make exceptions for
but you you got to look at some other
people and say man let's give you a
chance to grow it's a big debate you
know the answerers who knows what the
right answer is hey there it's Chris
Weidner and I hope that you're enjoying
this interview that I did with one of
the legends of personal development and
if you'd like even more information and
great resources from the legends of
personal development all you have to do
is click on the link below in the
description and I've got plenty more for
you so with that let's get back to the
interview I want to tell you about an
experience I had and then and use that
as a platform for you then to tell us
the importance of this the importance of
a coach and the right coach when I was
11 years old I had a great job I was a
ball boy for the Seattle Super Sonics oh
wow seven years I spent and I started
shortly after the season started and we
were 2 and 11 and when we got to 5 and
17 the owner of the sonics at the time
said enough is enough eliminated the
previous coach Bob Hopkins who'd been
the cousin of Bill Russell and taken
over when Bill Russell left uh fired Bob
Hopkins and hired who became the
winningest coach in NBA history Lenny
Wilkins same players uh he made a couple
of adjustments same players went from 5
and 17 to reach the seventh game of the
World Championship same year we came
back uh we lost the world championship
that year uh to the what at the time of
the Washington Bullets next year we won
the World Championship same team
different coach what is the importance
of a coach and what does a coach do that
turns those same people around and
enables them to go from 5 and 17 to
making it to the seventh game of the
World Championship winning the World
Championship the next year what does a
coach do what what's what's the
importance of a role and whether it's a
coach or a business owner Mom and Dad
same role what's the importance of yeah
let's let's you know um let's start with
what a dad is and how that you know a
dad is a guardian of a dream when a kid
is is born there's they're given skills
and talents and a and a father and a
mother they're they're there to to help
that dream come alive and true and and
really lead the kid not push them not
beat them not press them but encourage
courage and draw them into their dream
and those children that that have
parents like that um they're free
they're free to compete for that dream
and they and they and they so often that
they get there they the the journey is
so awesome it doesn't even matter if
they finally get to the end of the deal
a coach is no different a coach must
create a dream that the players buy into
and the players must have ownership in
that dream and some coaches are really
good at that they understand it's not
just about X's and O's when you get to
that level it's about the heart and the
passion of the people that are playing
for you and it's about the mind it's
about being able to get them up and and
manage the interference in their life
and the in the whole world of
professional sports and some people have
a knack for doing that others are really
good at technicians and they're really
good with x's and o's and and the great
coaches I believe the greatest coaches
of all times um have this ability to
reach in and to create a dream that
people can believe in and they want to
be on that bus and they want to be a
part of that and so they join in and
they take their talents and their gifts
and they and they strip off the fear of
failure and they get after it and um
that's the that's the power of influence
in a person's life the words that we
speak as a coach as a leader absolutely
will influence like how tell because I
think that's a really important
Point what do we say how do we say it in
order to bring alive you know there's
the old proverb that says the the tongue
has the power of life and death and it's
really true and a coach a parent a boss
how does that work what we say and how
it it inflames something in somebody
well language is the great influencer I
mean it's that's what connects us and
the words you know language is made up
of words and different words have
different
meanings what we have to understand when
we're leading people is that the same
word can mean something different to
someone else
for for a young man that comes in from
the city the inner city respect is a big
deal for that young man and to and to
say a word um of failure towards that
person in the context of a group of
people is a is a real is a real symbol
of disrespect for another kid that grew
up in a military family um and they walk
in and and you and you and you challenge
them in front of a group it's yes sir
I'll do it I'll be better next time you
get a totally different response our job
as Leaders is not to come in and say my
way or the highway I just don't believe
in that it's to it's to lay the
groundwork of what you expect but then
understand that people are motivated and
inspired differently and you got to
carefully very carefully watch the words
that come out of your mouth we did a
when I was a professor at the University
of Kansas for 12 years I I shered a lot
of dissertations and thesis and one of
my students wrote his dissertation on um
on uh NCA division one basketball
coaches and we we sent a question out to
all the basketball coaches who would be
the role model coaches uh for young
coaches to look up to and and the the
leading candidates were shashy and Dean
Smith and Denny crumb and Roy Williams
and John Wooden and my student went out
and interviewed these guys and he looked
for commonalities and there was a couple
of them they all said this that their
purpose really was to get their team on
the court with confidence idence that
was an agreeable Point among them that
that if if if I could really boil it
down to I want my kids to put their foot
on the maple on Game Day believing that
they can be successful so the followup
questions how do you do that and every
one of them agreed with this formula
with a little different number they said
for every criticism for every mistake
correction for every weakness that you
point out you better come back with
three positives Roy said I think is more
like eight 8 to one or three to one and
so that young people that are coming up
they want to be the best they want to be
coached they want to get there if you
want to build somebody strong you don't
beat them up and break them down see
that's a model that we sort of grew up
with and that leaves a lot of people and
talented people on the on the outskirts
because for whatever reason they came in
and they crumbled under those words
however if we' use different words you
build strength you build power these
people are able to to realize some
dreams in the past we didn't have time
time was an issue so you come in there
with the guns blaring you say Do It My
Way of the highway get it done now
screaming and hollering and we bring in
a military model because in the military
you got bullets coming at you and it's
life or death in sport it's not yeah you
know and we've got people coming from
all different backgrounds they're not
coming in to go to war they're coming in
to accomplish a goal in a mission and
and they can be tough and you can be
hard on them and all that stuff but the
issue is are you more positive than
negative and we just know this that for
most people and these coaches every one
of them agree these are what you know
these are the coaches that they said
would be the role models for the for the
future Generations they all said more
positive than negative Rick patino spoke
before me on a platform the other day he
said if you're not more positive than
negative you need to get out of coaching
he said that's the biggest change in his
life of coaching from where he was to
now is the switching from negative to
positive people people understand that
as you move through life well what's
interesting is when you list those names
they are names that we all know because
they're winners you know you listed off
that name of basketball coach and I'm
thinking uh-huh sure yeah yeah yeah
that's what yeah and it's because
they're winners and they're winners I I
find the the connection between the two
to be very interesting it's it's the
people who recognize that become the
winners they're the ones who win the
they win the competition but they also
win the hearts and they're the ones
whose kids keep coming back to the
colleges to visit him you know who was
far and above all of them is John Wood I
was going to say probably and you know
what my student called him and John
Wooden said you can come to my house and
he spent an entire day in John wooden's
House John Wooden gave him an entire day
of time to speak about this issue he
thought it was so important a student I
mean that's beautiful the story I love
about John Wooden is when uh Bill Walton
showed up and had a beard and long hair
and he said sorry Bill we don't have
beards on the team and he said well uh
I'm going to wear a beard and John
Wooden says well we're going to miss you
that's exactly right he headed straight
to the barber took it off and came
straight back and so you see he wasn't
negative he said I appreciate your
conviction yeah we're going to miss you
yeah instead of saying you called him
all kind of names and yelled at him he
just basically said I believe in your
conviction conviction is important but
we're really going to miss you on this
team so you lay down The rules there's
there's there's two ways to coach one is
what we
call conditional acceptance and the
others called unconditional acceptance
let's just take it in terms of being a
college
coach I ask the coach this question I
always ask them you know which one would
you lean towards and they say well what
do you mean I said here's conditional
coaching the team shows up day one and
you look at him and say here's the deal
you do this you do it my way and you do
it with intensity and passion and you
never miss a step and maybe you'll play
on this team but I'm telling you what
every one of you is Expendable and you
need to understand that and if you get
out of line you're out of here now you
understand that that's conditional so
the players come in understanding that
if they don't make a mistake then
they're okay and that if they don't make
a mistake long enough they might get to
play and if they don't get make mistakes
in the big games they might even get a
pad on the back someday that's
conditional acceptance the other coach
sees them and they come in they go you
know something you are the most prized
possession in the world to the parents
that sent you here and I count it an
honor to have you be a part of this team
now let me tell you something first and
foremost this is a family and you know
what there's differences in families and
there's going to be arguments and
complaints and things like that but you
look around this is our family and I
want you to know I'm going to honor that
and as long as you're here you're going
to play on this team and be a part of
this family I love you I want you to
know that right up front deal all right
you'll never ever ever wonder if I love
you or not or if you're part of this
team now let me tell you the rules you
better show up and you better show up on
the on the right time I'm going to push
you harder than you've ever been pushed
before because I care about you because
I have a dream about this program and I
want you to be a part of that and if we
get there at the end of that dream
you'll know why I pushed you so hard but
you'll never question that you're a part
of this team
unconditionally I want you know I love
you now that's a different that's a
different these people are pushed as
hard as these people but these people
play out of the fear of failure and
these people play out of acceptance I'll
tell you a story about that you want to
hear a great story it was University of
Nebraska volleyball volleyball team in
1995 and their coach great friend
tremendous individual his name is Terry
Pettit um was coaching and they were
into semi-final game and uh uh going to
the national championships he had had a
21-year mission to bring in a national
championship to Nebraska and they're
getting close but in this particular
game the other team had the momentum and
it was near the end of the game and I'd
ask him that question earlier in the
year about this conditional or
unconditional coaching and it and it
affected him he we talked deeply about
it and he said I want to say this but
maybe I'm not all the way there whatever
I mean he just he's a great philosopher
and he really wants to take things to
heart and build that into his program
it's near the end of the game they've
lost some momentum the other team has
now scored several points in a row and
it's out of they're losing it the dream
is over and he calls timeout it's just
about at the end and he says the team's
coming towards him he says I have no
clue what I'm going to say to this team
he said I'm not a you know big hugger
big you know lovable huggable bear like
some coaches might be I'm you know I'm I
love the girls I'm serious we we do
business and and um and I teach I'm a
teacher but he said they came to me and
they looked looked at me and they were
looking for something they were looking
for Hope because they had lost it they
lost momentum and all the girls circled
around him and he said I don't know
where it came from but it just started
bubbling up from the inside and I looked
at him and I just slowly moved my eyes
across the room around that little
huddle I looked every girl in the eye
and I said I want you to know something
whether you win or lose this match I
love you very very
much and he turned and sat down that was
it the other team's over there
diagramming plays and they're doing
their ex's nose and all this kind of
stuff and they're still 20 seconds to go
on the timeout or whatever and his girls
they just got tears in their eyes they
almost just burst out in tears and as he
walked out of the Huddle the Huddle
closed they put their arms around each
other and they said let's go they walked
out on the court and they just stared at
the other team waiting for them to come
out something changed in their hearts
the other team came out and they served
and it was in the sudden death back then
and Rally Point was going and Nebraska
scored and scored and scored and scored
and scored and won the other team had no
chance at the honors banquet at the end
of the year every girl they end up
winning the national championship every
one of the girls every single one of
them said coach and they looked at him
the season turned on a dime when you
told us that no matter if we win or lose
you loved us and you know what it did
it freed them up it took all of the fear
of failure and it freed them up and that
I don't know one more coaches can't do
that I tell you the ones that I admire
do Roy Williams I love that guy he did
that he does that um you know he was one
one I was as close to at Candace as any
uh they're able to do that the players
understand that they care I think the
the the issue of Roy moving to North
Carolina probably hurt
him that decision harder than anybody
else finally making it and who can blame
a guy for going
home his dream when he was a kid in
North Carolina was coaching North
Carolina
basketball and he turned Kansas
basketball into something that was so
amazing yeah and he built something and
to leave that broke his heart because he
knew that it was going to break some
people's heart but he's going home who
could blame you know who could blame a
is that the same in America that okay so
it's one thing you're talking about a
team they travel together and they're
they've got this big common purpose now
we take it into what the typical viewer
is looking at they've got a team they
run a small little small business 14
employees or maybe they're part of a
division of a larger company they got 50
employees is the same relationship and
the interactions between is is it the
same thing the boss has to let them know
uh look we have relationship regardless
of performance is there what what's the
similarities I cannot see a difference I
can't and some people might say I'm
naive I can't see it I I speak like you
do with hundreds of Corporations around
the country top ones I mean you know
they're the one two and three some of
the top corporations in America I've
been with and I would I would say this
if they asked the question and that is
this what's the meaning of an
organization when you have a name uh you
name an organization you have that the
name up here that entity what does it
mean it it is defined by people it's
defined by a number of people right and
it doesn't matter if there's a product a
service or whatever all business is
defined by people first those people can
create it those people can sell it those
people can Market it those people can
communicate withs and be a team and make
it happen it's always about people first
and when you come into an organization
and say instead of saying you've got to
sell out for this organization which is
just a name it's a name given to Define
people you got to sell out to this this
mon moniker whatever it
is then we're wrong I I I keep waiting
for and and I I know a few people that
do this for the day that that an
organization walks in and let's say I'm
inter you for a job and the first
question I ask you is number one tell me
about your family number two tell me
tell me about your passion tell me about
the Legacy you want to leave in life
what is it that you're really
about and you tell me about that and
then I tell you a little bit about mine
I'm see I'm I'm going to hire you I mean
how many how many guys have ever heard
that because I know something what makes
this man's heart
tick is what I want to capture in my
organization and if I have interest in
that then I believe that person is going
to be loyal that person is going to be
hardworking now
once I find that out I'm going to say
here's the position we have and this is
who we are let you and I discuss for the
next two hours this is not a 10-minute
interview how your passion dream Legacy
and love for your
family can be encouraged enhanced and
brought
about with the position we have for you
right here how can our organization help
you get
there are you serious that's that
doesn't happen very often are you
serious and if we find out that the
salary and the and the and the issues
around this the ability to teach you
leadership skills and the opportunity
for you to do community service because
I'm not going to make you work 80 hours
a week and and and the life balance and
all the stuff that we have in this job
I'm going to push you I'm going to
encourage you I'm going to hold you to
the task I'm going to you know have to
follow rules but if you know that my
deal as a leader as an organization is
that you're important that you're family
first and that my my job is to help you
reach your legacy and if the point at
which this job can't help you do that
anymore I want to help you find another
one are you going to come to work
differently is your is your family going
to stand at the door and go go Daddy go
I want you working for that organization
because they care about you like we care
about you what is wrong with our
organizations in America today is that
people are going to work for a check and
they know that just like in sport
professional sport at times they can be
number and they have a they have a they
have a you know a life cycle and if the
job isn't done and it isn't done
yesterday we'll get somebody else in
there and all business struggle struggle
with this whole um you know
transitioning of old and new and old and
new and all that if we could keep people
longer and they know that we're sold out
for them first and that the organization
is just a name and it's really here to
help the people in our organization
reach their legacies my gracious that's
how you build a winning team that's how
you build championships in sport that's
how you make kids strong that's how
families grow why would it be different
it has to be more than a check because
sure does they're just coming to work
for a check then you got problems I I
sat next to u a gentleman who spent most
of his career as a second even sometimes
third string quarterback and and we were
sitting next to each other at a lunch
and and somebody made reference to it
cuz it was a close nit group there's
about 40 of us and we knew him so
somebody poked a little bit of fun at
him being and I turned him I said I
always thought the best job in the world
would be second string quarterback all
that money with none of those hits and
he chuckled a little bit he said yeah
but at that level we all like to play
yeah and and it was you know here's me
going boy I'd love to make $3 million a
year sitting on the sideline with a
clipboard and a ball cap and he's saying
no I want to I want to be in the game
yeah all Champions want to be in the
game yeah all Champions want to be in
the game I want sh gears and ask you a
question there are people who dominate
their
Industries winners for long periods of
times names like Tiger Woods Barry Bonds
Wayne Gretzky Tom Brady although he's
probably still yet we'll go to Joe
Montana um are they Unique Individuals
that other people cannot repeat or are
they individuals who over the course of
experience Etc have unlocked the keys to
winning regularly I mean I I've got this
theory that the difference between Tiger
Woods and the guy who's number 150 on
the on the on the money list prob not a
lot in terms of swing and I mean they're
all really really good I would say with
the names that you mentioned that we
have this is the wrong term but the
perfect storm coming together sure what
you have is people that are physical
Geniuses that come together with mental
toughness and great great ability to
deal with
interference and and you bring those two
things together and you create a Michael
Jordan he created Tiger Woods he created
Wayne Gretzky unbelievable Talent so I I
think the honest answer to that is that
these people are special physically and
they're special mentally
now the issue the real issue in life is
there's a lot of people that are gifted
physically that don't understand what
you and I teach right and they they're
150th on the money list or they're 200
or they're in the CBA or they're an NBA
bust because they haven't
understood the importance of this
they're not disciplined in the mental
side or maybe more importantly they
weren't parented that way I think that
one of the keys of Tiger Woods there's
some great stuff about Tiger Woods that
I golf is my field and I and I love I
love the study of Tiger Woods is
parenting great parents his parents knew
he was special early and his dad was the
guardian of his dream he took him and
moved them forward and um the other
thing about
Tiger Tiger does one of the things we
talk about in in success and that is
you've got to be self-referenced you're
when you look in the mirror you got to
say am I better against that person in
the mirror today than I was yesterday
instead of am I better than that guy am
I better than that guy and that and that
that the greatest measure of success
that we have is the person staring back
from the mirror and so
Tiger Woods wins the US Open at Pebble
Beach several years ago I think he's 26
years old he shoots 12 under par he wins
by 15 shots the next closest guy's
overpar three Strokes he sets the
all-time record for the US opening at
Pebble Beach and breaks numerous records
he's
26 unbelievable and so they ask him
what's left for
you great answer he said well Butch and
I were just talking this is back when he
and Butch were together we were talking
on the Range yesterday on Saturday and
he
said we we've come to the conclusion
that I'm only about 70% there I've got
30% of improvement to do and you know
what he did a couple years later two
years later after he got sort of hit a a
ceiling for him yeah he changed his golf
swing retooled the whole thing didn't he
and everybody got on the bandwagon of
what's wrong with tiger why would he do
that all these other guys in the past
that have changed their swing some of
them never showed up again why would he
jeopardize that oh by the way he's
married now and there's a big
interference and all this stuff bye-bye
tiger you'll never get back and then
this year somebody asked him the
question they said they said why did you
change your swing why did you go through
all that and he said one 2 one and they
said what do you mean he said that's how
I finished in the last three Majors
first second and first next question
cool yeah I love the way he interviews
yeah you know those guy those great guys
they have a they have a they have a
composure about them they're great
interviews they're gracious people and
they
perform they grew up wanting the ball in
their hand at the end of the game you
got to want that yeah so there's a lot
more people I believe that can could be
there that don't get there because they
don't have what we're talking about I
want to give you this uh definition that
I love and it it fits well because it's
whether you're in sports or you're in
business and this is about game day mhm
performance equals potential minus
interference you mentioned the word
interference a couple times talk to us
about that that equation performance
equals potential minus interference
every person I work with we start with
that formula and that's the reason is
this the potential is not enough on Game
Day game day is a place that uh is a cin
of pressure game day is an environment
unlike any other environment and and for
people business they they understand
what game day is about they have game
day moments or game day weeks or game
day months you know we're talking about
performing your best when it means the
most the big presentation that's it it's
one thing to do it with your little crew
as you're prepping it's another thing to
walk into the client who's deciding
whether you're going to spend $100
million do on an ad campaign exactly
right you know or having to respond to a
situation that's critical to the future
of this business or your position or
whatever it might be game day is
different and when you look at game day
you see
the distractions that are um not normal
the interference points number one the
the the the voices in your head the fear
of failures and the perfectionist voice
and the and the and the the uh uh this
is it voice and the uh conservative
voice they're all competing for your
attention and then we have the past how
you've done in this situation in the
past then we have the future like just
think if this happens you could hold
this trophy or you could get that
promotion or you would be seen as this
and all of that stuff is just flooding
in
when it has nothing to do with anything
the issue at hand is can you take the
skills and talents and abilities that
you know to be true at a moment in time
and focus in on that and get the job
done everything else is interference
game day is just a great a
to watch how people filter through
interference and align their mind to the
purpose at hand I you know focus is a
big deal and to be able to filter and
focus is huge and that's the difference
between an or ordinary ex you know
situation and game day so why would I
prepare an athlete with the X's and O's
why would I prepare an athlete with
strength training and and and practice
in scrimmage if I never addressed what
it's like walking into the Super Bowl
yeah you got to be kidding me yeah why
would I why would I have a guy
hit I love golf I do a lot of work in
golf it's the worst practice sport in
America why do we pound thousands of
balls for those that do and they're very
good players on a perfectly level quiet
practice range on perfectly manicured
grass with the same Club over and over
when the US Open is next week at shinok
Hills and the wind's going to be blowing
30 m hour grass is this deep and the
rough is that deep and I've got the
cameras on and I'm paired with some of
the best players in the world I better I
better understand that the beating of
the balls is a part of sort of getting
me physically ready but if I don't
address the environment in which I'm
about to walk into I got no chance and
that's where people go oh next time I'm
in that environment I'll be ready let's
don't wait let's don't wait you don't
get to go to Super Bowl all the time you
don't get to get in an NBA championship
all the time when when the opportunity
knocks you better be ready to open the
door yeah because Destiny comes by only
a few times in your life we have a lot
of people who are in sales and of course
all of life is sales you know we're
always selling um and and one of the
questions I hear regularly and I want to
kind of have you walk us through a real
practical step by- step I hear a lot of
people say how do you not get nervous
when you're going to speak in front of
people and and there are people who just
as part of their job they have to speak
in front of three or four people some
people every now and then 3 or 400 walk
us through what you might tell somebody
who their game day is going to be making
a presentation doesn't matter if it's
big or small but they they just don't
like it they don't feel right about it
what would what would you tell somebody
what are the real practical steps that
you tell somebody to prepare uh as
they're getting ready for giving a
presentation so that they're not
thinking about all those things that get
them
away all right let's think about it
it what in that setting distracts you
the most you know what is it for most
people it's failing in front of a bunch
of eyes right
or forgetting their lines or thinking
they don't have anything to say so let's
deal with the fear of failure start with
because they're in that formula that my
success or failure as judged by these
people it has a lot of meaning in this
particular setting so let's deal with
let's deal with that thing first let's
understand what this whole let's let's
understand what the perspective the
right perspective with which we're going
in there for number one and then
secondly do you have anything to
say Do you believe in what you're going
to say is what you're going to say
important if it's not then don't do it
but if it is then then wouldn't it be
important for these other people to have
it and to know it do you have enough
conviction in what you have the material
you're going to share that it just might
make a difference in somebody's life and
if you do then we've got another step
let's talk about the people that are
coming why are they coming they're
they've got some questions they've got
some issues they need some information
do you have something do you have
something that can that that can trigger
a thought a process a movement in their
life I think I do do you know you do I
know I do are you important are you
doing something that's that's something
you can be passionate about then do it
now when information is given it it can
transform a
life
whether it's done with
perfection or whether it's done with
passion just make sure you're passionate
about what you share you don't have to
be perfect nobody wants perfect they
don't want slick they want real they
want authentic can you be authentic are
you an authentic person do you believe
in what you're going to say if so now
let's practice it and let's take
everything that's knocked you out of the
game in the past and let's just talk
through those things I call that mental
tough mental toughness training take the
issues that have knocked you out dispel
the lies um bring out the truths and get
somebody excited about what they're
going to share one last question sure I
know that your uh purpose one of your
purposes in life is to help people
fulfill their Destiny whether it's in
sports business
life give us a a brief comment on what
it means to fulfill your
destiny oh my goodness I just believe
that each
person has a distinct purpose for being
here and at the end of our life we need
to know that we made a difference and
that we took the skills and talents and
gifts that we've been given and that we
used it to the fullest
and we need to surround oursel by people
that believe that about us and share our
dreams and goals with other people we
need to have dads that are guardians of
their dreams we need coaches to be
Legacy coaches to people we need
employees to really get after it and do
that with people but at the end of the
day it isn't about success success is
part of the journey and if you think
right and have the right perspective
you'll have a lot of success but in the
end was did I make a difference and
that's all about your legacy and it's
people have got to spend time looking
for
it sometimes I get frustrated at public
schools because we spend so much time
teaching math and English and writing
and all that stuff I'm I'm not upset
about that part I'm just upset that we
don't help
people find and discover their dream and
their legacy and then help them help
them get there a class on life coaching
success in terms of
success with that's part of the journey
but not an end and a means by itself
fascinating stuff thanks for being with
us apprciate so welcome to see Chris's
interview with Jim ran which was the
last time Jim ran did a video interview
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there what you're about
to watch is the last video interview
that Jim ran ever did he sits down with
Chris Widner to talk about how to get
the right mentors set meaningful goals
and stop being broke